unser planet wird immer wärmer und wärme
co2 einsparen ist das gebot der stunde
einige staaten haben bereits das aus für
verbrenner autos in die wege geleitet
und irgendwann würden uns unsere
fossilen rohstoffe sowie so ausgehen
früher oder später müssen wir also auf
einen nachhaltigen antrieb für unsere
autos umsteigen
aber welchen e autos sind doch gar nicht
so umweltfreundlich wie man immer sagt
oder der akku muss unglaublich
energieintensiv hergestellt werden was
natürlich co2 produziert die materialien
die da drin sind werden alles andere als
umweltfreundlich gewonnen und wenn der
akku einmal brennt dann wird es richtig
gefährlich da könnte doch die
brennstoffzelle in der alternative sein
sowie in diesem wasserstoff fahrzeug
hier ich weiß noch vor 15 jahren da habe
ich immer wieso präsentationsprüfung
halten müssen zum thema wasserstoff
erzeugt und unsere prognose war damals
irgendwann fahnen und auch mit
wasserstoff fahrzeugen herum ist heute
noch nicht so aber vielleicht ist das
die zukunft ob das tatsächlich so ist
das sieht man bei ihr auf dem kanal dazu
gerne hier oben auf das i klicken und
bei uns geht es wie gesagt um e autos
denn wir wollten es mal genau wissen man
heute unglaublich viele mythen zum thema
e autos und wir haben tatsächlich bei
der recherche einige spannendes
herausgefunden nämlich ja es sind heute
schon umweltfreundlicher sind auch heute
schon günstiger als verbrenner man alle
kosten mit einberechnet und für die
allermeisten menschen kosten tatsächlich
weniger zeit beim aufladen im vergleich
zum sprit tanken warum das ist darum
geht es heute bei doktor watson
reviews in the ground
zehntausende von menschen sterben in
deutschland an den folgen von
luftverschmutzung fuß partikel und
stickoxide aus autoabgasen
ok als allererstes volle transparenz ich
fahre seit knapp zwei jahren elektrisch
und bin deswegen wahrscheinlich etwas
voreingenommen davon kann ich mich
leider nicht frei machen
ich selber halte elektrisch fahren für
sinnvoll und finde dass mehr leute
elektrisch fahren sollten
ich finde aber auch dass ich eigentlich
zu diesem thema mehr sagen kann als die
meisten gerade beim thema
alltagstauglichkeit fahrspaß
ladeinfrastruktur ladegeschwindigkeit
kann ich euch aus meiner persönlichen
erfahrung berichten
trotzdem hat natürlich die wahrheit hier
oberste priorität ich habe hier keine
agenda ich will wirklich die wahrheit
über elektroautos herausfinden und
manche aspekte von e-autos sind eben
scheiße zumindest noch deswegen
verlinken die zu jeder aussage zu jeder
studie die wir haben zu jedem artikel
oder jedem experten jetzt was in diesem
video sagt natürlich die quellen
wenn ihr meine videos schon länger kennt
dann werdet ihr wissen dass unten links
manchmal so zahlen auftauchen die
korrespondieren zu den entsprechenden
quellen die unten in der video
beschreibung verlinkt sind um rieso zu
zitieren ihr wisst wenn ich so ein video
mache mache ich es ordentlich und hier
sind alle themen über die wir heute
sprechen werden ihr selbst gar nicht so
wenige details dazu sind unten in der
video beschreibung verlinkt und damit
sollte auch hier die youtube timeline so
eingeteilt sein wenn ihr also direkt zu
einem bestimmten thema springen wollt
könnt ihr das einfach hier im youtube
player machen und ihr seht es sind
ziemlich viele themen also lasst uns
direkt anfangen die wahrheit über
elektroautos
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die mission ist das steht auf vielen
autos drauf aber das stimmt überhaupt
nicht
die autos haben sehr wohl emissionen nur
werden diese nicht dort aus gestoßen wo
das auto fährt und versteht mich nicht
falsch das hat immense vorteile
wir wollen auf jeden fall daran arbeiten
feinstaub und stickstoffoxid aus unserer
atemluft zu bekommen und dafür sind
e-autos ein guter anfang gar keine autos
in der stadt wären allerdings noch
besser da auch e-autos über reifenabrieb
und selten auch die bremsen feinstaub
erzeugen
aber uns geht es heute vor allem um die
co2 emissionen inzwischen haben
wahrscheinlich viele von euch gehört
dass e-autos einen co2 rucksack haben
die herstellung des akkus kostet eine
menge strom und deswegen verursacht ein
e-auto in der herstellung mehr co2 als
ein vergleichbarer verbrenner oft hier
die berühmt berüchtigte schweden studie
aus 2017 zitiert bzw
eigentlich eher das was ein journalist
aus dieser studie heraus gezogen hat er
berichtete nämlich dass bei der
produktion einer 100 kilowattstunden
batterie über 17 tonnen co2 entstünden
das entspreche einer fahrtdauer von
circa acht jahren bei einem verbrenner
diese aussage wurde zahllos zitiert und
übernommen und hat damit leider mega
großen schaden angerichtet denn es gibt
viele menschen die deswegen immer noch
glauben dass e autos gar nicht
klimafreundlicher wären als verbrenner
dabei gibt es gleich mehrere probleme
mit dieser aussage zum einen haben die
allerwenigsten autos 100 kilowattstunden
akku ist eigentlich sogar nur das tesla
model s und iks und der audi e-tron und
der porsche kann haben weit über 90
kilowattstunden
aber die gab es damals noch gar nicht
als diese studie rausgekommen ist die
meisten akkus zu mehr zwischen 30 und 70
kilowattstunden groß und benötigen somit
auch nur ein bis zwei drittel des stroms
in der herstellung
dann handelt es sich bei der studie des
evl in schweden um eine metastudie die
die ergebnisse anderer studien
analysiert und zusammenfasst und diese
anderen studien hatten teilweise
komplett unterschiedliche ansätze und
kam zu unterschiedlichen zeiten raus und
waren damit teilweise veraltet und dass
man acht jahre fahren müsste um einen
verbrecher in dem co2 emissionen wieder
einzuholen ist alleine schon quatsch
weil ihr zum beispiel nur der direkte
co2 verbrauch gerechnet wurde
für benzin und diesel muss ich aber auch
öl gefördert transportiert raffiniert
und wieder transportiert werden all das
verursacht co2 ein paar andere details
gibt's ja auch noch aber eigentlich will
ich mich ja gar nicht zu lange mit einer
studie beschäftigen
an anderen stellen schon wesentlich
ausführlicher analysiert wurde um wie
gezeigt einfach falsch ist
2009 10 veröffentlicht das evl dann eine
anschlussstudie und aktualisierte die
zahlen was auch aufgegriffen wurde
trotzdem geistern diese 17 tonnen immer
noch als fakt durch die gegend okay aber
wie viel co2 verursachen die autos der
jetzt wirklich nun das ist ziemlich
schwierig pauschal zu benennen zum einen
weil es nicht dass eine e auto gibt und
zum anderen weil fast keiner der
hersteller mit konkreten zahlen
ausdrücken will tesla versteckt sich in
seinem impact report immer nur hinter
vagen aussagen über den willen möglichst
viele erneuerbare energien einzusetzen
und vw sagt dass bei der herstellung
eines id 33 und 40 prozent der
co2-emissionen auf die batterie
entfallen wie viel das genau sind aber
nicht die zweite studie des evl aus 2009
10 mit aktuelleren zahlen geht aber zum
beispiel von durchschnittlich 61 bis 106
kilogramm co2 pro kilowattstunde
batterie aus im schlimmsten fall soll
das 146 seien auch goethestraße forscher
an der eindhoven university of
technology rechnet auf basis von
aktuellen studien und industriequellen
mit 65 kilogramm pro kilowattstunde
und auch die internationale
energieagentur zu der auch deutschland
gehört nutzt diese zahl was in diesem
zusammenhang oft erwähnt wird der co2
ausstoß der akkus geht mit der zeit
runter das liegt vor allem daran dass
akkus immer effizienter produziert und
dabei immer mehr erneuerbare energien
verwendet werden
und das ist einer der wichtigsten punkte
von e-autos sowohl bei der produktion
als auch beim fahren profitieren sie
stark von grünem strom und wasser strom
wird von jahr zu jahr immer grüner
aber das sind ja nur die werte für den
akku in der herstellung wie stehen denn
jetzt e autos wirklich im vergleich zu
verbrennen da wenn man den gesamten
lebenszyklus mit einberechnet die gibt
es eine menge studien die sich aber
leider oft widersprechen das ist extrem
mühselig sich hier durchzuführen
meistens kommen studien zu einem anderen
ergebnis weil sie irgendetwas vergessen
oder falsche annahme gemacht wurden zum
beispiel wird nicht mehr angerechnet das
benzin und diesel nicht nur beim
verbrennen im auto sondern auch bei der
herstellung und den transport co2
erzeugen oder es wird außer acht
gelassen dass sich unser strommix immer
weiter verbessert was man auf jeden fall
in die kalkulation der nächsten jahre
mit einbeziehen sollte diack
erste studien die ich finden konnte die
alle aspekte einkalkuliert und den
kompletten lebenszyklus von autos
betrachtet ist diese hier von der
technischen universität eindhoven im
auftrag der grünen bundestagsfraktion
und da hat auch aufgehübscht raum mit
gemacht wäre ich ja vorhin schon erwähnt
habe
nach dieser studie ist zum beispiel ein
testmodell 3 mit unserem strommix in
europa nach 30.000 kilometern
klimafreundlicher als ein vergleichbarer
mercedes c220 dem auf die gesamte
lebenszeit der beiden autos gerechnet
wohl sagt der tesla 65 prozent weniger
co2
bei kleineren autos sieht es ähnlich aus
einem golf stößt 54 prozent weniger co2
als ein toyota prius aus und hat seinen
co2 rucksack nach 28.000 kilometern
wieder aufgeholt gearbeitet wurde hier
mit einem durchschnittlichen wert von 75
kilogramm co2 pro kilowattstunde für die
herstellung der batterien
außerdem geht man davon aus dass e auto
und batterie 250.000 kilometer gefahren
werden was für viele jetzt
wahrscheinlich nach sehr viel klingt
aber tatsächlich realistisch ist dazu
gleich noch mehr leichte kritik gibt es
aber trotzdem und zwar aus der fachwelt
für das co2 äquivalent pro
kilowattstunde unseres strommixes doch
das ändere nichts an der kernaussage der
studie sagte ein experte dem spiegel
okay gut aber trotzdem welcher studie
kann man denn jetzt trauen wenn man mal
wieder irgendetwas vom co2 ausstoß von
elektroautos im internet liest das
wollte ich von professor doktor volker
quaschning wissen er ist promovierte
elektrotechniker und professor für
regenerative energiesysteme an der
hochschule für technik und wirtschaft in
berlin und ihr kennen ihn vielleicht von
seinen eigenen videos hier auf youtube
oder aus resources die zerstörung der
cdu video also man hört ja mal das
argument dass ein elektroauto ja sogar
noch schlechter wäre als ein benzin oder
diesel auto hast die klimabilanz
anbelangt da gab es einige studien dazu
wenn man sich als wissenschaftler da mal
rein liest dann haben diese alle
meistens systematische fehler entweder
veraltete zahlen oder einfach wirklich
äpfel mit birnen verglichen
also wenn ich ein gleichwertiges
elektroauto mit einem gleichwertigen
verbrenner vergleiche dann sind ganz
klar die zahlen so dass die klimabilanz
des elektroautos heute auch schon besser
ist es eigentlich auch vollkommen egal
welches momentan besser ist die frage
ist wie 17 10 jahren aus das heißt wenn
ich jetzt ein benzin oder diesel
autokauf wird der verbrennt in zehn
jahren immer noch benzin und diesel
das heißt er stößt genauso viel co2 aus
wir bauen aber unsere stromversorgung um
das heißt das elektroauto was jetzt
vielleicht noch ein bisschen
kohlekraftwerke im netz hat das wird
dann in zehn jahren einfach auch mit
noch
erneuerbaren strom haben das wird halt
immer klimaneutraler und wenn wir dann
die produktion auch noch klimaneutral
haben dann kriege ich das elektroauto
klimaneutral hin
diese chance habe ich mit dem verbrenner
nicht und deswegen sind für mich diese
studien eigentlich rein akademisch das
heißt die frage ist wie kriegen wir den
verkehr klimaneutral und das geht mit
dem diesel definitiv nicht zwei wichtige
take aways hier erstens 65 prozent
weniger co2 ist immer noch verdammt viel
co2 die autos sind klimafreundlichere
autos als verbrenner aber sind immer
noch autos das klimafreundlichste wäre
gar kein auto zu fahren
solche statistiken zeigen zum beispiel
fast nie wie viel co2 es kosten würde
mit der bahn oder dem fahrrad zu fahren
diesen vergleich sollte man aber
eigentlich machen ganz kurzer hinweis
wir konnten hierzu leider keine zahlen
finden die den ganzen lebenszyklus
berechnet haben also auch die
herstellung und entsorgung von bussen
oder zügen deswegen ist der unterschied
vielleicht nicht ganz so eindeutig wir
haben diese unsicherheit mal visuell
dargestellt
aber manchmal geht es eben nicht ohne
auto und da kommt take away nummer zwei
ins spiel
der große co2 rucksack kommt von der
energieintensiven akku herstellung wenn
man die aber mit co2 neutralem strom
machen würde dann würde das e-auto
insgesamt noch mal viel besser dastehen
und genau da bewegen wir uns ja
eigentlich gerade hin wir müssen sowieso
schnell eine klimaneutrale
energieversorgung hinbekommen verbrenner
autos werden aber immer benzin oder
diesel verbrennen und damit immer co2
ausstoßen egal wie gut der strommix ist
ach ja und julia sind zwar eine super
spannende technologie aber leider keine
lösung für autos warum habe ich sie
schon mal erklärt
[Musik]
akkus von elektroautos basieren
prinzipiell auf derselben technologie
wie zb akkus im smartphone- oder im
laptop lithium ionen dafür braucht man
zum beispiel lithium nickel kobalt
mangan und kohlenstoff fun fact ihren
nichts davon sind seltene erden bisschen
wie das eigentlich metalle der seltenen
erden
das wird ganz oft falsch wiedergegeben
seltenerden braucht man maximal im
elektromotor aber nicht in der batterie
und auch dagegen die uns nicht einfach
aus denn der name hat nichts damit zu
tun dass sie wirklich selten in der
erdkruste vorkommen
und auch bei den anderen rohstoffen wird
es nicht knapp studien aus den jahren
2009 bis 2015 legen nahe dass es genug
rohstoffe gibt um den bedarf für die
batterieproduktion zu decken
es gibt sogar wesentlich mehr als wir
eigentlich bräuchten es könnte höchstens
zwischendurch eng werden wenn es
probleme bei der erschließung neuer
vorkommen oder der förderung gibt das
sagt ein faktencheck des fraunhofer
instituts für system und
innovationsforschung isi
außerdem kann theoretisch viel aus alten
batterien recycelt werden
nickel und kobalt zum beispiel bis zu 90
prozent und mehr
beim lithium allerdings nur ein viertel
bis die hälfte je nachdem wie viele
batterien auch wirklich zum recycling
gebracht werden wenn dann einer batterie
recycelt wird mindestens die hälfte des
lizenz kann dann zurückgeholt werden und
das wäre auch ziemlich wichtig denn
sowohl die gewinnung von lithium als
auch von kobalt sind problematisch
lithium wird zu einem großen teil in
australien gewonnen aber unter anderem
auch in chile argentinien und bolivien
wo viel wasser dem sowieso schon
trockenen boden entzogen wird und
indigene völker darunter leiden ein
großteil des wassers ist zwar schon
vorher versalzen es gibt jedoch einfach
kaum untersuchungen oder studien die
sich mit den auswirkungen auf die umwelt
und die siedlungen dort beschäftigen
unter anderem auch deshalb weil die
betreiber der mine das verhindern
hier wäre das vor allem an den
autoherstellern druck auszuüben um die
folgen zu untersuchen und den abbau zu
optimieren oder gegebenenfalls sogar
einfach zu stoppen denn wie gesagt ein
großteil des lithium wird in australien
unter ganz anderen bedingungen abgebaut
dass es eine ganz andere methoden kobalt
wiederum wird zu großen teilen in der
demokratischen republik kongo gewonnen
teilweise im kleinen bergbau unter
lebensgefährlichen bedingungen
gearbeitet wird und sogar kinder
eingesetzt werden
auch darauf habe ich volker quaschning
in unserem interview angesprochen und er
hat wie ich bin mir etwas sehr
spannendes gesagt haben die probleme
also bald kommt aus demokratischen
republik kongo oder gibt es kinderarbeit
nicht an der tagesordnung ist in
rohstoff wie alle anderen auch genauso
problematisch wenn ich mir jetzt den
katalysator angucke beim auto oder als
platin und sonst irgendwas drin also
auch kein unproblematischer rohstoff
aber im elektroauto gucken wohin ich
finde es gut weil zum ersten mal schauen
weil wirklich hin bei den produkten das
müssen wir nun als auf alle anderen
produkte auch übertragen das elektroauto
nicht zu kaufen löst das problem nicht
die kinder arbeiten kongo ist ja nicht
da weil jetzt irgendwo tesla hingegangen
ist und sagt komm ich versklaven jetzt
kinder und wenn mein kobalt abzubauen
kobalt wird dort schon seit jahrzehnten
abgebaut das wird verwendet für farben
für flugzeugtriebwerke beim t shirt ist
er nirgendwo in bangladesch bei der
schokolade eine millionen kinderarbeiter
wenn ich ein verbrennungsmotor mehr
kaufe dann habe ich eine batterie am
ende die wird in den entwicklungsländern
entsorgt wir haben über 100 millionen
kinder die eine bleivergiftung haben
weil wir hier in die batterien
unsachgemäß und sorgen da hat bislang
keiner hingeschaut diese ganzen probleme
die wir kennen sie wissen sie wir machen
die augen zu durch das elektroauto ist
es ein thema geworden und jetzt sehen
wir zum ersten mal auch soziale projekte
wo die autohersteller weil der druck da
ist auch dafür sorgen dass die produkte
das kobalt dann wirklich freundlichen
gewonnen wird und deswegen können wir
dann das auch beseitigen das heißt die
konsequenz aus den missständen ist nicht
das auch das elektro auto zu verzichten
und das bei allen rohstoffen darauf zu
achten dass diese fair gehandelt und
produziert werden und das müssen wir
beim elektroauto bei allen produkten
auch machen und dann glaube ich können
wir guten gewissens auch ein elektroauto
kaufen wenn ihr noch tiefer ins thema
elektromobilität einsteigen wollt dann
könnt ihr euch das gesamte interview mit
volker quaschning bei uns auch pajun
ansehen
es ist nämlich wirklich sehr spannend
was uns noch alles erzählt hat wir
konnten leider nur ganz ganz kleine
teile davon hier in dieses video packen
einfach aus zeitgründen außerdem hilft
es uns auf eure unterstützung zu
bekommen auf petri
dann können noch mehr solcher videos
hier machen links unten in der video
beschreibung genau so wie zum
youtube-kanal von volker quaschning und
vielen dank an alle patches die dieses
video hier möglich gemacht haben eine
sache finde ich übrigens noch
erwähnenswert und zwar den tesla battery
day im september 2020 darstellte ihnen
maske eine menge spannender dinge vor
die alle dafür sorgen sollen dass
batterien
liga besser und mit einer höheren
energiedichte hergestellt werden können
unter anderem durch eine neue
materialzusammensetzung die komplett auf
gewalt verzichtet stattdessen soll
stärker auf nickel gesetzt werden was
batterien insgesamt deutlich günstiger
machen soll und nun ja dass man keine
kinderarbeit unterstützt ist natürlich
auch ganz praktisch aber das wollte man
wohl auf der bühne nicht zu sehr betonen
außerdem sprach moskau von eine neue
methode der lithium gewinnung entwickelt
zu haben die keine säuren benötigt und
in den usa stattfinden sollen
tesla ist sich also bewusst dass hier
etwas passieren muss und arbeitet
tatsächlich daran seine rohstoffe auf
ethisch vertretbare arten und weisen zu
gewinnen
ein weiterer aspekt beim everyday war
die energiedichte aktuell haben lithium
ionen batterien eine energiedichte von
ganz grob 250 wattstunden pro kilogramm
dieser wert könnte allerdings in den
nächsten jahren auf 400 wattstunden pro
kilogramm gesteigert werden
das sagt übrigens nicht nur in den
masken sondern auch das fraunhofer hier
ist alleine durch das neue batterie
design von tesla soll eine steigerung
der reichweite um 54 prozent möglich
sein und dabei werden e autos sowieso
schon immer effizienter isolation
elektronik leichtbau aerodynamik all das
wird ständig optimiert die batterie wird
besser ins auto integriert so dass die
teile des autos wird und man weniger
gewicht für die karosserie mitschleppen
muss und software optimierungen spielen
auch eine große rolle
all das führe dazu dass sich die
reichweite von elektroautos in den
kommenden zehn jahren verdoppeln könnte
so das fraunhofer institut und das
obwohl es heute schon die autos mit über
650 kilometern reichweite auf der straße
gibt
wir stehen hier wirklich noch am anfang
der forschung und entwicklung und ich
habe noch gar nicht von solid state
akkus oder kaffee in akkus oder glas bzw
keramik akkus angefangen all das könnte
noch kommen und die autos noch weiter
verbessern
übrigens halten aktuelle akkus schon
jetzt deutlich länger als man das
vielleicht von smartphones oder laptops
gewohnt ist in der studie aus eindhoven
wurde ja mit 250.000 kilometern über das
gesamte leben des autors gerechnet und
das ist gar nicht unrealistisch tesla
gibt an dass die batterien im model s
und model x320 1000 kilometern weniger
als 20 prozent kapazität verlieren und
das deckt sich auch mit den daten die
unabhängige tesla fahrer in einem forum
seit einigen jahren
und als ob das noch nicht genug ist
haben viele batterieproduzenten jetzt
die eine million meilen batterie
angekündigt oder auch 1,6 millionen
kilometer ist nicht ganz so ketsch ii
aber das muss es auch gar nicht sein
denn wie krass ist das denn 1,6
millionen kilometer die meisten normalen
autos fahren zwischen 200.000 und
400.000 kilometer und werden dann
verschrottet viele dieser batterien
könnten also ohne probleme
die lebensspanne ihres autos überleben
und dann kann so einer batterie auch
noch ein zweites leben bekommen und zum
beispiel als stationärer stromspeicher
eingesetzt werden um erneuerbare energie
zwischenzuspeichern
und was passiert mit den batterien wenn
sie wirklich tot sind kann man die
recyceln grundsätzlich ja bisher ist
aber leider noch sehr wenig über die
wirtschaftlichkeit des recyclings
bekannt in der eu müssen aber hersteller
für die kosten von sammel aufbereitungs
und recycling systemen aufkommen wobei
es irgendwann wahrscheinlich günstiger
und sinnvoller sein wird die rohstoffe
aus alten batterien zu recyceln
anstatt die elemente aus der erdkruste
zu gewinnen dann könnte ein zirkel
entstehen und man müsste kaum noch neue
rohstoffe schürfen
doch bis es soweit ist muss noch einiges
passieren die aktuell größte
recyclinganlage für
lithium-ionen-batterien kann bis zu 7000
tonnen im jahr behandeln
das sind gerade mal 3000 bis 5000 e auto
akkus pro jahr
auch die umweltbilanz von recycling
lässt sich bisher nur schwer abschätzen
wahrscheinlich gibt es einen vorteil in
bezug auf den treibhausgasausstoß aber
diese vermutung fußt nur auf labor
maßstäben
ich habe dieses skript hier mit euch auf
petri an geteilt und dort nach feedback
gefragt und ein großer punkt war spricht
doch auch darüber wie schlecht
eigentlich verbrenner autos sind
ich habe diesen punkt ursprünglich nicht
mit reingenommen weil das hier die
wahrheit über e autos ist wirklich die
wahrheit über verbrenner und auch vor
allem weil ich hier keinen what about is
und betreiben möchte trotzdem habe ich
das gefühl dass bei solchen diskussionen
eigentlich fast nur das e auto
angegriffen oder verteidigt wird aber
wir reden fast nie über die alternative
stickstoffdioxid steht zum beispiel in
direktem zusammenhang mit krankheiten
wie diabetes mellitus bluthochdruck
asthma oder schlaganfällen und ist jedes
jahr für mehrere tausend vorzeitige
todesfälle
alleine in deutschland verantwortlich in
verbrennern stecken auch metalle der
seltenen erden wie zum beispiel cer
lanthan oder yttrium und für platin dass
man für katalysatoren braucht werden
menschenrechte verletzt die förderung
von öl sorgen immer noch regelmäßig für
umweltkatastrophen erst letztes jahr hat
brasilien das schlimmste öl um
glück seiner geschichte erlebt und wie
viele kriege wegen öl geführt wurden
kann ich gar nicht aufzählen das dazu
ich finde das macht die probleme von e
autos nicht weniger stimmen
aber das argument e-autos sind auch
nicht perfekt dafür zu benutzen um alles
so zu belassen wie es gerade ist ist
einfach nur dumm
[Musik]
aufladen während aktuell hier noch 23
kilometer restreichweite drin wir wollen
jetzt mal schauen wie viel wir in einer
zeit in der man typischerweise tankt
aufladen kann
[Musik]
reichweiten angst das ist nicht nur
etwas was youtuber und influenza haben
sondern manchmal auch elektroautofahrer
und immer wenn es um autos geht kommt
dieses thema reichweite irgendwo hoch
komme ich mit meinen wenigen kilometern
überhaupt zum ziel
wie lange muss man aufladen ich hab
gehört dass dauer tätigkeiten also gut
reden wir darüber
hier kann ich euch wie gesagt aus erster
hand berichten da ich seit anfang 2019
komplett elektrisch unterwegs bin ich
damals in der zeit bevor alles den bach
runtergegangen ist bin ich noch
regelmäßig quer durch deutschland
gefahren hamburg berlin münchen
frankfurt alles kein problem ich bin
noch nie irgendwo liegen geblieben oder
muss ich mir gedanken machen wie ich zu
meinem ziel komme das laden jetzt in
deutschland ist so gut ausgebaut dass
man quasi nicht liegen bleiben kann wenn
man es darauf anlegt auf ladesäulen
register de kann man sich alle
öffentlich registrierten ladepunkte
ansehen und es gibt kaum einen punkt in
deutschland der weiter als zehn bis 15
kilometer von einer ladesäule entfernt
ist zumindest wenn man sich auf einer
straße befindet wenn ihr mit eurem auto
mitten im wald kein strom mehr habt dann
seid ihr irgendwo selber schuld wie
schnell man dann da lädt dazu kommen wir
gleich aber das ist eigentlich gar nicht
so wichtig denn zwischen 60 und 85
prozent aller ladevorgänge finden
schätzungen zufolge zu hause statt
ich selber bin hier die ausnahme ich
kann weder zu hause noch an meinem
arbeitsplatz aufladen und bin somit auf
das öffentliche ladenetz angewiesen
und das ist nicht im sinne des erfinders
für die meisten bedeutet aufladen nach
dem parken zu hause oder im büro
den stecker einstecken und dann acht
stunden arbeiten oder bis zum nächsten
morgen zu hause leben
es kostet keine zehn sekunden und es
damit insgesamt zeit sparen da als
verbrenner auftanken denn da muss ich ja
einmal die woche oder so zur tanke und
immerhin fünf minuten oder so da blöd
rum stehen und noch bezahlen und alles
die allermeisten menschen fahren am tag
in weniger als 100 kilometer
viele sogar weniger als 20 selbst mit
einem elektro smart der nur 100
kilometer reichweite hat
würden also um 89 prozent aller
autofahrer klarkommen und über nacht
kann man jedes auto mit elf kilowatt
wieder komplett aufladen wenn man also
nicht gerade ein vertreter ist der über
500 kilometer am tag fährt und
zwischendurch absolut gar keine zeit für
stopps hat oder man keine möglichkeit
hat zu hause oder auf der arbeit
aufzuladen ganz das e auto total
alltagstauglich was viele leute noch
davon abhält ist die eine fahrt pro jahr
in den urlaub
im durchschnitt waren die deutschen im
sommerurlaub 885 kilometer das sind pro
strecke also knapp 450 kilometer ein
durchschnittliches auto hat aber nur 200
bis 400 kilometer reichweite
das bedeutet aufladen und hier wird
spannend super nintendo ja ich bleibe
mit meinem auto nicht lieben aber wenn
ich dann eine ladestation gefunden habe
dann ist es zumindest in deutschland
wahrscheinlich eine art c ladestation
mit 11 oder 22 kilowatt also ziemlich
langsames laden
da stehe ich unter umständen eine
geschlagene stunde für gerade mal 50
kilometer reichweite was natürlich
totaler quatsch ist und noch mal auf die
karte geguckt gibt es durchaus gegenden
in deutschland wo im umkreis von 50 und
mehr kilometern keine schnell ladesäule
zu finden ist
auf wichtigen autobahnen ist das
allerdings besser bereits 2018 gab es
durchschnittlich alle 60 kilometern
autobahnstrecke eine schnelle at säule
heute ist es gefühlt nochmal deutlich
besser aber ich konnte dazu leider keine
statistik finden
unter umständen muss man hier also ein
bisschen voraus planen wo man dann lädt
auf dem weg zumindest wenn das auto das
nicht für einen übernimmt und schnell
laden bedeutet beide way nicht wirklich
das was es suggeriert viel schneller da
sind 50 kw was ungefähr 250 kilometer
reichweite für eine stunde laden
bedeutet als auch das ist nicht
besonders schnell aber gar nicht die tut
sich einiges
er lade park in hilden zum beispiel wo
man seit kurzem mit über 300 kw laden
kann
40 supercharger für teslas 22 fassenden
punkte und weitere 52 langsamer als die
ladepunkte sind insgesamt geplant
und hier ist übrigens auch alles
überdacht schön beleuchtet und es gibt
sogar ein café und einem kleinen teich
so sollte das aussehen nicht so wie die
meisten ladepunkte ja wer elektrisch
fährt der braucht auf langen strecken
mehr zeit und das wird auch noch lange
so bleiben
wenn man mit durchschnittlich 150 kw
laden kann was gar nicht so schlecht ist
dann sollte man für alle sieben
mit 50 km eine stunde nur fürs laden
einrechnen
in der praxis macht man dann eher 4 15
minuten lange pausen bei der akku in den
unteren prozent bereichen schneller
laden kann
aber das ist so ungefähr die
größenordnung und vergessen nicht dass
man die reise mit einer vollen batterie
antritt die ersten paar hundert
kilometer gibt es also quasi geschenkt
und wie sieht es in den städten aus je
mehr leute auto fahren desto mehr werden
wie ich nicht die möglichkeit haben zu
hause oder im büro aufzuladen
sie brauchen aber natürlich trotzdem
strom und hier ist die situation von
stadt zu stadt komplett unterschiedlich
münchen und hamburg sind zum beispiel
super
beide haben über 1000 öffentliche
ladepunkte die gut in der stadt verteilt
sind
berlin ist mit etwas unter 1000
ladepunkten zwar nur knapp dahinter
aber auch eine größere stadt und für
mich persönlich ok aber in köln wo ich
lebe ist die situation mit gerade mal
159 punkten mega ätzend in diesem
riesigen innenstadtbereiche zum beispiel
gibt es nur zwölf ladepunkte und die
hälfte davon sind in parkhäusern für die
man noch mal extra bezahlen muss
immerhin will man hier bis mitte
nächsten jahres 400 neue ladepunkte
bauen stand märz 2020 gibt es in
deutschland rund 27.700 öffentliche und
teil öffentliche ladepunkte 14 prozent
davon sind schnell da dagegen stehen
grob 200.000 e autos das ist okay aber
im juli 2020 wurden in deutschland
dreimal so viele autos zugelassen wie im
juli davor
wenn jetzt der e auto buchen so langsam
kommt können wir dann noch alle laden
oder müssen wir schlange stehen nun das
ist schwierig zu sagen überall findet
gerade ein ausbau des ladennetzes statt
die anzahl aller öffentlichen
ladepunkten in deutschland wuchs 2009 10
in einem jahr um 50 prozent und ein
immer größerer anteil davon sind schnell
lada trotzdem wenn die zahl der e autos
in die höhe schnellen sollte dann könnte
es zu engpässen kommen sagen experten
hier sollte also weiter ausgebaut werden
und damit zurück zum lade park in hütten
ok ziemlich perfekt wir haben jetzt fünf
minuten 40 geladen und dabei ziemlich
genau 100 kilometer reichweite
aufgetankt das ist auch genau die zeit
die ich darüber das thema aufladen
gesprochen habe und in der zeit hat
dieses auto etwas über 100 kilometer
reichweite mittag das reicht um jetzt
noch mal über eine stunde autobahn zu
fahren bis wir das selber nochmal machen
müssen
in der realität wird man wahrscheinlich
eher 15 minuten aufladen kann dann aber
dementsprechend auch er 200 300
kilometer fahren
ein punkt ist glaube ich alle zwei
stunden 15 minuten pause machen ist
wahrscheinlich eh besser für die
konzentration und auch für die blase auf
der anderen seite das hier ist ein super
charger kein anderes auto aus einem
tesla kann hier laden und das ist ein v3
supercharger dienst in europa noch fast
gar nicht gibt ja es gibt andere
öffentliche ladestationen wo man mit 200
kw und mehr laden kann zum beispiel fast
mit oder ohne ti aber nicht jedes auto
kann mit solchen geschwindigkeiten
umgehend es gibt viele autos die können
wir mit 100 kw oder sogar noch weniger
laden sie muss ich in der zukunft also
noch einiges tun damit nicht nur teslas
und andere teure e autos auf schnelle
geschwindigkeiten kommen und wenn einem
das wirklich komplett gegen den strich
geht und man wirklich nur fünf minuten
tanken dann direkt wieder fünf stunden
fahren will
oder man sich für einen elektro-smart
entschieden hat der nur 100 kilometer
reichweite hat dann kann man sich ja
einmal im jahr ein verbrenner mieten und
kommt insgesamt immer noch günstiger und
umweltfreundlicher damit in den urlaub
es wäre wahrscheinlich sowieso eine gute
idee oder smart ist das perfekte
stadtauto unter der akku so klein ist
ist die co2 bilanz hier nochmal deutlich
besser kleine autos leute die brings und
die helfen auch bei den
[Musik]
die umwelt zu schützen können sich nur
reiche menschen leisten das hört man
immer wieder
aber stimmt das wirklich nun ja wenn es
um autos geht tatsächlich nicht denn
wenn man wirklich alle kosten mit
einberechnet sind die meisten e autos
inzwischen günstiger als vergleichbare
verbrenner das konnten schon einige
studien nachweisen
zum beispiel diese hier von 2018 hier
hat man den vw golf in all seinen
ausführungen verglichen um zu schauen
welche die günstigste ist und in allen
fünf ländern der studie war die elektro
variante die günstigste auch in
deutschland dabei ist der e golf nicht
mal ein effizientes oder besonders gut
durchdachtes e-auto denn er verwendet
dieselbe plattform auf der auch
verbrenner gebaut werden
das bedeutet dass an vielen stellen
kompromisse eingegangen wurden die e
variante ist also höchstwahrscheinlich
ineffizienter als sie eigentlich sein
könnte und trotzdem ist das auto nach
ein paar jahren günstiger als ein
verbrenner der neue id3 sollte hier noch
besser abschneiden weil er von anfang an
als elektroauto designt wurde dann gibt
es noch diese studie hier die hat sich
verbrenner hybride plug in hybride und
batterie elektroautos in den usa
großbritannien und japan angesehen und
ist zu dem schluss gekommen dass e-autos
schon 2015 preis gleich mit
herkömmlichen autos waren bei beiden
studien gilt das allerdings nur wenn man
förderprogramme und steuervorteile mit
einberechnet aber die gibt es ja und
teilweise sind die seitdem sogar noch
größer geworden dass diese studien gut
zeigen ist dass sich die kosten eines
autos über viele jahre verteilen klar
den größten batzen macht natürlich der
preis des autos selber aus und ja da
sind e-autos noch teurer als
vergleichbare verbrenner aber bei den
laufenden kosten holen sie wieder ein
zum beispiel beim treibstoff für die
energie die in einem liter benzin steckt
zahlt man zwar weniger als für dieselbe
menge aus der steckdose
allerdings kann ich mit meinem auto drei
bis fünf mal so weit fahren mit
derselben menge energie
das zeigt wie effizient e-autos sind der
ottomotor so optimiert er inzwischen
auch ist gibt eine menge energie in form
von wärme an die umgebung ab viel mehr
als 40 prozent wirkungsgrad sind hier
einfach nicht möglich meistens sogar
deutlich weniger ein e-auto hingegen
kann bis zu 90 prozent der gedanken
energie in bewegung verwandeln wobei man
dazusagen muss dass es bei den aktuellen
spritpreisen in der krise kaum einen
unterschied macht ob man elektrisch oder
verbrenner fährt
ein auto das auf 100 kilometer 4,8 liter
verbrauch bezahlt aktuell ungefähr das
gleiche wie ein e auto mit einem
verbrauch von 17 kilowattstunden auf 100
kilometer aber gut generell wenn wir
nicht gerade in der krise sind ist das e
auto eigentlich günstiger weitere
laufende kosten entstehen auch durch die
instandhaltung und reparatur ein
verbrenner motor hat mehrere tausend
bewegliche teile wie alle aneinander
reiben sich verzahnen kraft aufeinander
ausüben
irgendwann bricht reist oder schmilzt
etwas einen elektromotor kann man
hingegen so designen dass er nur ein
einziges bewegliches teil hat in der
realität sind wahrscheinlich so um die
20 teile die einen tesla motor hat aber
es ist schwierig hier zu eine
verlässliche quelle zu finden
trotzdem zündkerzen kupplung
schaltgetriebe all das sucht man bei
e-autos vergeblich ausnahme zu letzterem
ist übrigens der porsche kann der als
einziges auto in der massenproduktion
zwei gänge statt nur einem hat aber egal
insgesamt muss man mit einem auto auf
jeden fall seltener in die werkstatt
auch zum beispiel weil man die
bremsscheiben seltener auswechseln muss
denn die werden bei autos viel langsamer
abgenutzt da ein e-auto mit den
elektromotoren bremsen und dadurch
bewegungsenergie zurückgewinnen kann und
will wechsel kann man sich natürlich
auch sparen
und dann gibt es noch ganz viele kleine
kleinigkeiten die man mal bekommt und
mal nicht je nach stadt land und e auto
kostenloses parken zum beispiel
günstigere versicherungen geschenkte
mautgebühren oder sogar kostenloses
aufladen
ich lade zum beispiel seit ich meine
auch du hier in köln habe komplett
kostenlos an den zapfsäulen der
stadtwerke
das soll sich zwar bald ändern aber über
anderthalb jahre lang habe ich nicht nur
weniger geld für meinen treibstoff
bezahlt sondern gar keins ok die autos
sind also in der anschaffung teurer
kosten dann aber in der haltung weniger
weil strom meistens günstiger ist und e
autos weniger reparaturen haben aber gut
ich weiß dass jetzt viele von euch
denken ist ja schön und gut dass die e
autos so toll und günstig sind ich kann
mir trotzdem keines leisten der
günstigste tester zum beispiel kostet in
deutschland aktuell knapp 44.000 euro
davon gehen zwar noch mal 6000 euro
umweltbonus ab aber der
durchschnittspreis eines neuwagens liegt
in deutschland bei 33.500 euro
und ganz ganz viele menschen können oder
wollen sich gar keinen neuwagen leisten
die allermeisten e-autos fangen bei über
25.000 euro an
das liegt einfach daran dass die akkus
noch sehr teuer sind und die produktion
auch noch in den kinderschuhen steckt
der verbrenner motor wiederum hatte 100
jahre zeit um jede kleinigkeit am motor
selbst und in der produktion am
fließband zu perfektionieren
auch hier zeigt sich wieder dass e-autos
noch viel potenzial haben
laut recherchen von bloomberg new energy
finance könnten e-autos schon ab 2025 im
kauf genau so viel kosten wie
vergleichbare verbrenner denn die preise
für akkus fallen gerade rapide
zwischen 2016 und 2030 könnte der preis
um 77 prozent sinken unter anderem tesla
ist ja ganz vorne mit dabei
wir hatten ja gerade schon über den
battery day gesprochen da sagte ihnen
macht auch das tesla mit dem neuen
design
die kosten pro kilowattstunde batterie
um bis zu 56 prozent senken könnte
ein batteriepack mit 80 kilowattstunden
kapazität könnte dann nur noch um die
dreieinhalb tausend euro kosten
und ja ich weiß dass dieses video ein
bisschen tesla harry ist ich bin kein
fanboy von tesla und schon gar nicht von
allem aber man muss sagen dass tesla auf
diesem gebiet einen meilen weiten
vorsprung vor der konkurrenz hat es wird
noch länger dauern bis erst tesla diese
geringen preise erreicht und dann stück
für stück auch der rest der branche
aber das zeigt dass e-autos auf einem
sehr guten weg sind wer trotzdem schon
heute elektrisch fahren will der kann
sich auch ein gebrauchtes auto kaufen
gute autos mit wenig laufleistung gibt
es hier schon ab 10.000 euro
die haben diesen kosten rucksack gar
nicht erst und sind in der haltung
trotzdem günstiger als benzin und diesel
das ganze thema e auto kosten habe ich
übrigens in einem video auf dem kanal
von yello nochmal viel ausführlicher
besprochen als ich jetzt hier die zeit
dafür habe
da rechne ich zum beispiel für euch auch
mal durch was ich für mein auto genau
bezahlen wenn euch das anschauen wollt
dann könnt ihr jetzt hier oben klicken
ansonsten verliere ich das video aber
auch noch mal im abspann und in der
video beschreibt
[Musik]
ok fahrspaß
ich denke inzwischen wissen die meisten
von euch dass elektroautos nicht langsam
sind wahrscheinlich kam der gedanke
ursprünglich mal von golf carts oder den
aller ersten e autos aber spätestens
seit tesla war klar
die autos können richtig schnell sein
bis zum beispiel wirklich keinen
langsamen autos gewohnt aber er ist
vorher noch nie auto gefahren das tesla
model 3 performance kann in drei
sekunden von 0 auf 100 beschleunigt und
das merkt man vor allem verbandes
schwere kamera in der hand hält das auto
beschleunigt so schnell dass es mit fast
einem geh nach vorne prescht man wird
also beinahe so stark nach hinten
gedrückt wie man von der erdanziehung
angezogen würden
der neue porsche cayenne turbo s kann in
unter 2,8 sekunden von 0 auf 100
sprinten und im tesla model s ist es
noch krasser mit one foot rollout wurden
hier bereits 228 sekunden von 0 auf 100
und 1,2 gg gemessen
das ist also nicht nur so als würde man
aus einem flugzeug springen und im
freien fall sein ist das quasi so als
würde man dabei noch in den rücken
getreten werden
123 nicht mit da kannst du jeden porsche
an der ampel
irgendwann muss ich jetzt durch nicht
benutzen aber gut das sind ja auch
sportwagen normale e autos beschleunigen
nicht ganz so krass schlagen aber ihre
direkte verbrenner konkurrenz fast immer
von 0 auf 50 und fühlen sich einfach sie
begannen das liegt an den elektromotoren
und ihren sofortigen drehmoment während
benziner und diesel ständig schalten
müssen um immer im optimalen
drehzahlbereich zu bleiben kann ein
elektromotor von null bis 16.000
umdrehungen je minute und noch mehr
arbeiten und diese 0 ist ganz wichtig
die bedeutet nämlich dass e-autos sehr
gut aus dem stand beschleunigen können
von 0 auf 50 oder 100 und das macht
natürlich vor allem in der stadt spaß wo
es viele rote ampeln geben
ich denke diesen unterschieden werden
die meisten fahrer bemerkten sobald man
in ein auto steigt egal wann man aufs
pedal drückt es passiert sofort etwas
ohne dass die motordrehzahlen
hochgefahren werden müssen oder in
welche gänge runtergeschaltet werden
müssen
ok jetzt schon die ganzen motorsportler
schreien beschleunigung ist gar nicht so
wichtig und das vergleichen von null auf
hundert zeiten ist für die rennstrecke
totaler quatsch
und das stimmt auch auf dem nürburgring
sind andere daten viel wichtiger
nichtsdestotrotz fahren die
allerwenigsten menschen auf der
rennstrecke
sie fahren auf der straße und da wird
man nicht so krass um die kurve gehen
sondern ihr beschleunigen aber gut ohne
jetzt hier zu tief ins detail zu gehen
die autos kommen gerade erst im
rennsport an können aber teilweise schon
sehr gut mithalten und lassen die
verbrenner manchmal sogar alt aussehen
ein vollelektrischer vw ideale steht
aktuell auf platz zwei der ewigen
nordschleife rekordzeiten und auf platz
eins immerhin ein hybrid und obwohl ein
tesla model 3 performance einige hundert
kilo schwerer ist als ein bmw m 4 gts
fahren beide die rennstrecke laguna seca
in kalifornien in derselben zeit der
tesla kostet allerdings nur die hälfte
bei längeren strecken gt autos aber
trotzdem recht schnell die puste aus
nicht unbedingt weil sie keinen strom
mehr haben sondern eher weil die
batterie zu überhitzen droht dann wird
die maximale leistung reduziert und man
fährt und beschleunigt nicht mehr so
schnell
das passierte beim tesla model s noch
sehr schnell das tesla model drei kühe
schon wesentlich besser da passiert aber
trotzdem noch und der porsche kann kann
inzwischen 30 mal in folge hart von 0
auf 200 kilometer pro stunde
beschleunigen ohne zu limitieren
auch hier zeigt sich ersten sind noch am
anfang der entwicklung und werden
ständig besser und besser
aber es gibt eine sache die autos nicht
können und auch niemals können werden
[Musik]
elektromotoren sind leise sie sind nicht
still je nachdem mit welchem auto man
fährt kann man die motoren arbeiten
hören aber sie sind leise auch beim
rekuperieren können die motorengeräusche
machen aber klar dass es nichts im
vergleich zu dem sound den verbrenner
machen
und hier bin ich persönlich
zwiegespalten klar auf der landstraße
kann es richtig geil sein
den motor aufheulen zu lassen oder im
tunnel mit offenen fenstern wenn man
weiß dass man allein ist das klingt ein
und das macht bob aber 98 prozent der
zeit bin ich mega froh dass man auch
keine geräusche macht wie oft kommt es
vor
man ist in der stadt unterwegs unterhält
sich nett und irgendein meint den motor
aufheulen zu lassen
da ist mehr oft
[Musik]
aber selbst auch mal mit einem ganz
normalen verbrenner unter 100 ps fährt
beim start macht der motorgeräusche ich
wohne in der straße die so gebaut ist
dass die häuserwände den schein ganz gut
reflektieren und ich bekomme sehr gut
mit wer nachts um halb drei
irgend jemand sein auto startet und
wegfährt jedes mal wenn ich mit meinem
auto unterwegs bin bin ich froh
niemanden zu stören
an der ampel in der stadt kann ich ohne
probleme schnell beschleunigen ohne dass
ich direkt alle zum juden drehen finde
ich persönlich besser so ist er
unterwegs zu sein und es sollte doch
einfach für eine angenehmere stadt
atmosphäre wenn alle elektrisch fahren
würden ich meine wenn es autos nicht
geben würde und man würde sie jetzt
gerade neu erfinden dann ist ein
geräusch der kein feature
es ist ein bug ein fehler man braucht
keine geräusche um sich
vorwärtszubewegen es ist ein
nebenprodukt an dass wir uns über die
vielen jahrzehnte gewöhnt haben
was man jetzt präferiert laut oder leise
ist natürlich geschmackssache
einige autohersteller haben angefangen
fake sounds in die e autos zu spielen
damit man mehr feedback bekommt übrigens
nichts neues 61 gibt es auch schon bei
verbrenner autos aber wie gut sich das
wirklich anhört muss jeder für sich
selber entscheiden
übrigens ist das nicht zu verwechseln
mit dem ton den die autos nach außen
abgeben
[Musik]
seit 2009 10 muss jedes neu zugelassene
auto modell in europa unter 20 km h
einen ton abspielen um fußgänger auf
sich aufmerksam zu machen und ab dem
ersten juli 2021 gilt das für alle neuen
autos also auch modelle die bereits vor
2019 zugelassen wurden
mein tesla hat das nicht was ich
persönlich ehrlich gesagt ganz gut finde
weil dieser spaceship sound echt komisch
ist
aber ich muss zugeben dass ich schon
häufiger das problem hatte dass sich
fußgänger die vor mir laufen nicht
gehört haben da muss man entweder warten
bis sie das von selber merken und dann
muss das fenster herunterkurbeln und was
sagen
oder man muss gucken was die dann voll
erschreckt und was natürlich mega
unhöflich ist ist also tatsächlich kein
schlechtes feature vor allem für
menschen mit sehbeeinträchtigungen die
im straßenverkehr darauf angewiesen sind
dinge zu hören anstatt sie zu sehen
ab 20 km h beginnen dann irgendwann die
reifengeräusche lauter zu werden und mal
ganz kurzer exkurs deswegen sind e autos
auf der autobahn auch nicht wirklich
leise als verbrenner wind und
abrollgeräusche sind irgendwann
wesentlich lauter als der motor
zumindest wenn man nicht gerade stark
beschleunigt
[Musik]
ok dieses video das ist ja schon super
lang allerdings will ich noch auf ein
paar mythen eingehen die sich immer noch
wacker halten und die ganz oft als
argument gegen e autos verwendet werden
starten mit mythos nummer eins wir haben
nicht genug strom
laut dem adac würden zehn millionen neue
autos den stromverbrauch in deutschland
um 30 terawattstunden erhöhen
das wären 5,6 prozent vom gesamten
stromverbrauch klingt gar nicht mal so
wenig bis man erfährt dass deutschland
2009 10 über 35 terawattstunden strom
mehr ins ausland verkauft als eingekauft
wurde
darüber hinaus baut deutschlands sein
netz an strom reserven zum beispiel
durch gaskraftwerke weiter aus es wäre
also jetzt schon ohne probleme möglich
über 10 millionen elektroautos mit strom
zu versorgen aktuell fahren aber nur
200.000 e autos in deutschland etwas
mehr wenn man die plug in hybride
mitzählt außerdem wird ja gerade
generell überall daran gearbeitet
möglichst viel energie einzusparen egal
ob in der industrie beim licht oder bei
den geräten zu hause das macht natürlich
alles noch mal mehr energie für andere
dinge frei zum beispiel elektroautos das
nochmal zwei wenn wir alle gleichzeitig
laden dann bricht das stromnetz zusammen
da würde ich jetzt mal sagen klar wenn
jetzt ganz plötzlich alle 48 millionen
autos in deutschland zu einem
elektroauto werden würden und die im
selben moment ihre batterie laden würden
dann hätten wir ein problem ja aber es
laden eben nicht alle gleichzeitig auto
genauso wenig wie nicht alle menschen
genau gleichzeitig tanken fahren
der vergleich liegt etwas zugegeben weil
aufladen natürlich länger dauert als
tanken aber trotzdem gilt dass nicht
alle menschen gleichzeitig laden werden
man rechnet hier mit maximal 30 prozent
und schon gar nicht alle mit größerer
leistung zu hause hört man meistens mit
maximal elf kilowatt pro auto viel
weniger als beim aufladen an der
autobahn
trotzdem müssen wir auch hier in den
nächsten jahren ausbauen da es
mancherorts zu wenig trafos gibt damit
jeder haushalt ein e auto laden kann
es gibt ja also einen kleinen wahren
kern laut studien von energy ist es
übrigens aktuell auch ohne den ausbau
des stromnetzes möglich bis zu 1,1 e
autos pro haushalt zu laden wenn man
smarte lade vorrichtungen einsetzt durch
sie könnte der stromverbrauch und damit
die auslastung des netzes gesteuert und
entsprechend angepasst werden
wer von zu hause oder auf der arbeit
lädt der parkt sein auto in der regel
länger
als es zum laden braucht deshalb
bereiten sich netzbetreiber jetzt schon
darauf vor mit ladestationen zu
kommunizieren und so die auslastung zu
steuern
man bekommt also dann strom wenn dieser
gerade nicht irgendwo anders gebraucht
wird und trotzdem ist man dann am
nächsten morgen komplett aufgeladen zu
dem ganzen thema stromnetz habe ich
übrigens auch schon bei yello ein
ausführliches video gemacht
mythos nummer drei elektroautos sind auf
grund der batterien viel gefährlicher
hier wird es etwas komplizierter im
august wurde dazu ein interessantes
paper des eidgenössischen departements
für umwelt verkehr energie und
kommunikation in der schweiz
veröffentlicht dabei wurde bei tests mit
lithium-ionen-batterien in tunneln
festgestellt dass zwar die chemischen
gefahren andere sind als bisher
eine batterie brand für die passagiere
aber generell keine größere gefahr
darstellt als ein brennender verbrenner
was jedoch beachtet werden muss ist dass
die batterie brände aktuell nicht
wirklich löschbar sind sie müssen zwar
nicht über tage kontrolliert abgebrannt
werden wie man das vielleicht schon mal
gehört hat aber es muss erstmal
verhindert werden dass sich das
eingedämmten feuer neu entfacht sollte
eine batterie zelle in brand geraten
können durch die hohe hitze auch in den
umliegenden zellen kurzschlüsse
ausgelöst werden eine kettenreaktion
entsteht in diesen fällen ist kühlen
auch lodge der schweizer feuerwehr die
sinnvollste maßnahme
sonst kann der akku auch noch tage
später plötzlich wieder feuer fangen
da man im moment mit dem kühlwasser noch
schwer an das innere der batterie also
die eigentlich beschädigten zellen
herankommen könnten spezielle lupen in
der karosserie dass elektroautos helfen
das wasser direkt in die batterie zu
leiten sollte gibt zum beispiel schon
beim renault sorry
damit kann eine ausbreitung des brandes
verhindert werden bis das fahrzeug
gesichert und abtransportiert werden
kann
aktuell wird außerdem schon einen neuen
methoden geforscht die wasser als
kühlmittel ersetzen sollen und dabei
schneller und effektiver wirken wenn ein
elektroauto einmal brennt ist die gefahr
für die insassen nicht höher als bei
einem verbrenner das feuer entsteht
nicht schneller und ist auch nicht
heiser das höchste gebot ist also auch
hier alle raus aus dem auto und in
sicherheit bringen
auch die wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein
elektro auto brennt ist nicht annähernd
so hoch wie es immer gerne behauptet
wird laut einer einschätzung des adac
entstehen brände quasi nur bei einem
unfall
und auch da brennt ein e auto nicht
häufiger als ein verbrenner die
intelligenten systeme sorgen jetzt schon
dafür dass kurzschlüsse erkannt werden
und die batterie abgeschaltet wird bevor
sie einfach so zu brennen
diese panik vor sich selbst entzünden e
autos ist also nicht gerechtfertigt an
dieser stelle muss man aber noch mal
sagen dass autos generell für viele
verkehrstote verantwortlich sind egal
welchen antriebsstrang
sie verwenden in deutschland sind 2009
10 über 1300 menschen bei autounfällen
gestorben
elektroautos haben hier zumindest wie
die insassen zwar gewisse vorteile weil
es zum beispiel vorne kein motor gibt
und deswegen eine größere knautschzone
aber es bleiben autos und autos sind
eines der gefährlichsten verkehrsmittel
die wir haben
[Musik]
was ist also die wahrheit über e autos
erstens elektroautos sind jetzt schon
klimafreundlicher als verbrenner und die
co2 bilanz verbessert sich jährlich an
der rohstoffgewinnung muss aber
definitiv noch gearbeitet werden
zweitens elektroautos sind
alltagstauglich vor allem wenn man wie
die meisten zu hause lebt das ladenetz
wird immer besser wobei mehrere autos
natürlich auch weniger ladepunkte pro
auto bedeuten hier muss bald viel gebaut
werden drittens viele elektroautos sind
schon jetzt günstiger wenn man alle
laufenden kosten mit einberechnet
trotzdem sind sie in der anschaffung
noch teurer als verbrenner
wer nicht viel geld hat der wird sich
nur schwierig ein e auto leisten können
auch das wird in den nächsten jahren
besser und man kann davon ausgehen dass
neue autos irgendwann das gleiche oder
sogar weniger kosten werden als
verbrenner viertens elektrisch fahren
macht spaß aber kaum geräusche hier ist
geschmackssache ob einem das fehlen wird
auch gibt es keine manuellen e-autos
wenn man gerne schaltung fährt und
fünftens vor elektroautos muss man keine
angst haben zumindest nicht mehr als bei
herkömmlichen autos youtube sagt mir
ganz grob wer meine videos schaut und
die meisten hier sind zwischen 18 und 34
jahren alt
in dieser altersgruppe werden noch
relativ wenig neue autos gekauft und
generell kauft sich unsere generation
weniger autos und das ist was gut ist
wie gesagt das umweltfreundlichste auto
ist gar kein auto
aber es gibt menschen die auf ihr auto
angewiesen sind es gibt menschen die
können oder wollen auf ihr auto nicht
verzichten und es gibt menschen die
kaufen sich einfach jedes jahr ein neues
auto oder das gehörte einfach dazu wenn
diese menschen eure eltern freunde oder
bekannte sind dann schickt ihnen dieses
video hier
denn wenn es ein auto sein muss ist das
e auto jetzt schon die
klimafreundlichste wahl
und je schneller wir auf elektrische
antriebe umsteigen können desto besser
die größten bedenken die menschen über
ihre autos haben sind in der realität
gar keine großen probleme lange auf
ladezeiten sind meistens irrelevant da
zu hause geladen wird geringe
reichweiten sind irrelevant da man gar
nicht so oft weite strecken fährt wie
man denkt und man schnell laden kann und
die langlebigkeit der akkus ist auch
erwiesen
aber obwohl ich der meinung bin dass
batterie elektroautos generell
sinnvoller sind als wasserstoff autos
muss man ja sagen dass wasserstoffautos
all diese probleme nicht haben
sie tanken mehr oder weniger so schnell
wie man benzin oder diesel tankt können
ohne probleme 1000 kilometer reichweite
haben und sind von ihrer akkukapazität
nicht wirklich abhängig minister wissen
to go hat bei sich auf dem kanal
wasserstoffautos mal genauer unter die
lupe genommen und ich kann euch sein
video nur wir haben uns ans herz legen
darf einfach hier klicken und wie
versprochen auf dem kanal von yallo habe
ich darüber gesprochen was mein auto
genau kostet wenn euch das anschauen
wollt ein video geht runter ansonsten
wie immer vielen dank fürs zuschauern
vor allem wenn jetzt 30 minuten oder wie
lange das video auch geworden ist
durchgehalten habt und bleibt wie immer
neugierig patrick
[Musik]